be nice if I could get that excited
about seeing somebody I know from work
so new trailer not new trailer first
trailer for a thor ragnarok the third
Thor movie and I'm not doing a live
reaction to this one I am gonna I've
watched it several times now I'm gonna
have my more collected slightly less raw
thoughts then you know I did the last
few times I talked about new trailers so
what do I think about this there's a lot
to like here um there are a couple of
things that I want to say they they
concern me but they're a little like hey
like I'm not entirely sure how to feel
about the thing overall obviously
there's a ton of stuff to love Cate
Blanchett looks like she is ready to own
the screen as hella I love that look
when she's all black like the horns it
reminded me if you watch the TV show
Hannibal they had this sort of devil in
imagery of like all black with these
antlers it really reminded me of that
which for me that's a happy place that's
a nice thing to be reminded of I like
that you know the destruction of Mjolnir
that in itself would be something I
gotta be like oh but I mean that's
that's a really appropriate raising of
the stakes for a third installment and
also I'm because we've seen the only R
in more than just the Thor movies so
that thing's really been built up so the
idea of him not having it that's I would
say that's almost on par with Tony not
having the Iron Man suit for a big chunk
of Iron Man 3 so I think that's an
appropriate ramping up and an
appropriate sort of stripping down of
the character as well it's interesting
to sort of see how the pieces are going
to be fit together because we had seen
previously some you know behind the
scenes footage and like Jeff Goldblum's
look and whatever and that all felt very
guardians of the galaxy that didn't feel
particularly Thor and we're seeing how
this fits together now because it you
know once whatever has gone on in Asgard
has gone on and he's kind of kicked out
of there you know he ends up in
place that is a bit more guardians of
the galaxy esque and and sort of getting
that context it it all kind of makes
more sense and that's sort of where I
get that I'm not entirely sure how I
think of how I feel about this because
with the vibe of these sort of alien
creatures and certainly Jeff Goldblum's
character feeling so very Guardians plus
the use of the pop music in that and
that thought that was very 80s it felt
like a video game from the 80s the whole
thing feels like they are taking the
vibe and the feel of guardians of the
galaxy and sticking it onto Thor and I
have mixed feelings about that on the
one hand I don't like the idea of throne
of losing its own identity one of the
things I've liked about the Marvel
properties is that while they are kind
of consistent overall in many ways you
get a slightly different feel off each
individual franchise so the idea of the
vibe of one franchise kind of getting
transposed onto another is one that
makes me nervous it makes me worried
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe as a
whole is gonna become more homogenized
than it already is now that was some of
my gut feeling now that having been said
but I actually think about it it's like
do I actually love the existing vibe of
Thor all that much is it something that
I really feel a loss for losing not
entirely I mean I I liked the vibe off
there but it did it felt it's felt kind
of generic fantasy and it did it didn't
really quite click in a lot of ways the
way that h ed the way that on paper I
feel like it should have so while I'm
still kind of cautious about this
feeling more like another franchise in
Marvel's stable I have to admit I'm not
exactly bemoaning the loss of what Thor
kind of was as a franchise up to this
point so I can kind of roll with that at
this point I think but there are there
are a lot of great moments in this like
I said Cate Blanchett she looks awesome
we get a quick glimpse of ages Elba as
Heimdall so he's still out there
obviously we get a little glimpse of
Loki like basically just enough to
remind everybody yes Loki is in this we
didn't forget him but of course the big
centerpiece we
a little bit of Jeff Goldblum who's
running this arena and the gladiatorial
arena and the Hulk now I can only
imagine how awesome it must have been
for anyone who isn't like me and isn't
following you know the the ins and outs
of these things well ahead of when you
know this kind of material gets released
because I obvi was gonna be in this for
a while but I can't imagine how
thrilling it must have been for somebody
you know who didn't already know that
hope was gonna be in this to see that
but for me what made it exciting for me
even though I knew it was coming was
just Thor's reaction and then the
reaction to his reaction just that I
said it just silences the whole arena
and they're all just like yeah that's we
weren't expecting that one and of course
he had hoped for silicon of course
they're still gonna fight now in no way
it feels like we'd get a fair amount of
plot but there's also a ton that has to
be going on in this that we don't see I
mean obviously there was the bit teased
at the end of Doctor Strange he's
looking for Odin you know he's gotta
have to reclaim or rebuild or or avenge
whatever something in regards to Asgard
so I feel like we probably haven't
gotten any further than the halfway mark
I figured the the introduction of Hulk
has got to be the the sort of front end
of act 2 so I feel like while we've
gotten a fair bit it's all in the front
and it's all the set up kind of stuff
and I feel like they had they're holding
back from bigger climactic moments cuz
obviously you know him fighting with the
whole that's not what this thing is
building dude that'll be awesome but
it's not what's being billed to so
unlike say spider-man trailer which felt
felt like it gave the entire guild
outline of the movie this feels like
it's pretty detailed up to a point but
it's like there's obviously so much this
gotta happen past what we've seen I'm
perfectly fine with what they showed us
so overall like I said pretty excited
just slightly iffy about the the
borrowing of the guardians of the galaxy
vibe not to the point that of my oh it's
gonna suck which is like
in a general kind of intellectual sense
just sort of being nervous about the
individual franchises losing the
identities that they have a little bit
I'm not certain that that's what's gonna
happen this could be a case of mostly
marketing it's like I said it's things
like the title font and the use of music
which is probably not going to appear
directly in the but that was like that
if they were gonna go with with a pop or
rock song you know Led Zeppelin ow that
was a great choice definitely but just
the ghio just the use of that is all
very grounds to the galaxy ask
especially in terms of how courage the
galaxy gets marketed I am but you know
aside from maybe just this gladitoria
world feeling more of guardians Biasi
than others the film overall may still
feel more like Thor and this could just
be an aspect of marketing so I'm open my
eye and I do think I that this is
certainly given me many reasons to be
excited for this movie so the thor
ragnarok first trailer what do you think
whatever your thoughts were drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]